hi everybody
today i'm going to talk about a another
topic regarding
entomology specifically the importance
of migration to butterfly and moth
populations
migration is a very important part of
the life cycle of lots of butterflies
and moths
although it's not it's not very common
to be honest there's a lot of species
the majority of butterflies and moss
pieces are fairly sedentary meaning they
have very
focused ranges and they don't migrate
much but there are notable exceptions
and the way humans behave and the way
humans are stewards of their environment
is very important
to be able to map and track
and also protect the migration routes of
these particular
butterflies and moths so
probably the most important migrator
that i'm sure everybody has heard about
is the monarch butterfly the monarch
butterfly is
very well known and it is a very strong
migrator at least most populations are
and this species as an adult ranges from
canada all the way to mexico and
individuals over winter in the
mountains of mexico in the fur forest at
high elevation
and they have spectacular breeding
aggregations in the mountains of
mexico so a lot of people have a little
have some misconceptions about migration
like what what do they do do they all do
make the flight at once
um but they don't necessarily make the
flight at once
so this is an example of the queen
butterfly which is the same
genus the same family as the monarch and
the queen butterfly doesn't migrate very
much
very rarely most of these live in the
southeast us down into the caribbean
and also central and south america and
they have a very sedentary
existence they don't migrate much the
monarch
starts off in the spring in mexico and
individuals fly
up through basically through mexico into
the southern united states
through texas and california and
reproduce
so an individual monarch doesn't go from
mexico to say new york or connecticut
it will have several generations that it
takes to get
up from mexico to like basically the
northeast
because the butterflies don't live that
long there's a lot of challenges along
the way
so the butterflies that you're seeing
now like in the fall in connecticut are
going to be
several gen they're gonna be like one or
two generations separate from the moths
that left mexico
in the spring and then basically when
there's to get these subtle cues from
the environment
they turn around and decide to return to
mexico which is
a mystery that science is still trying
to figure out how they do this but it's
like
that when it gets cooler my the monarchs
turn around and start flooding back
south usually along the coast and a lot
of people see a lot of monarchs around
this time of year because monarchs are
extremely um like they're very sensitive
to cold so they cannot survive winter
temperatures in the northeast
so they have to immediately return south
so over
multiple generations again um these a
lot of adult monarchs will actually move
from
say the northeast down to the
mid-atlantic or the southeast
um and then have another generation and
then those
next generation monarchs will continue
to mexico or the caribbean
so again a single monarch usually
doesn't make the whole trip there might
be a few that are strong enough to do it
but most of them
take a couple generations to make the
trip
and so given our
basically how we can affect
my by graders becomes very apparent when
i talk about these next two
species which are called this is the
common painted lady which if you have
children a lot of people
sell rearing kits for these where
children can rear
and rear butterflies from eggs to adult
and they're called painted ladies
they're very common species
and this butterfly here is called the
common snout
they're called snouts because they have
a little like their palps are
kind of pointed into a it looks like a
nose this is another migratory species
and sometimes in the southwest these
things are so
abundant that there could be literally
swarms of billions of them
flying through the southwest and people
have drove through them and
it just darkens the skies there's so
many of these
so when it comes to migrators
the common denominator in a lot of these
is the southwest
so in the southwestern united states you
have a lot of
concentration of butterfly diversity and
a lot of our
species that we get up into the
northeast of all different types
pass through that area and so a big
challenge
for going forward for humanity is to
actually protect
the areas not only in the in mexico in
latin america where these species
overwinter
but also protecting habitat that these
species use as corridors
to basically fuel up for their journey
so
old farmland old fields abandoned areas
with flowers are very important
for basically preserving the habitat
of these butterflies and moths and a lot
of these butterflies actually
feed on like these feed on milkweeds so
if you have milkweeds in your yard
don't don't chop them down keep them
because these butterflies
will use them both for fueling the next
generation and also food
for nectaring so and another issue
is associated with the border wall
that's unfortunately
being proposed to going up along the
texas
and new mexico and california border
and this wall is having the adverse
effect of potentially destroying lots of
key habitat for butterflies and moths
right along the texas border
and there is a very strong center of
diversity in southern texas it's one of
the most
species-rich areas of all the areas of
the united states for butterflies
and actually the the butter one of the
major butterfly gardens
in southern texas is actually partially
destroyed by construction crews that are
building the wall
so even by doing things that seem to be
based more focused on humans they have
adverse
impacts on the environment by causing
that destruction to the habitat both to
the plants that the
insects depend on and also killing
potential
caterpillars eggs and pupae of adult
butterflies and moths as well